This is just a short public service announcement to say, um,
a belated goodbye to all the people who unfollowed me, um,
for being a human being.
And what I mean by being a human being is, uh,
caring about children, not dying in an illegal war.
So yeah, um,
love you and really happy that, um,
all of you other real, living,
breathing, feeling human beings are still here with me.
Um, I'm sorry if I offended anyone,
um,
by saying that I didn't think children should be orphans,
but that's not really my problem because it's not complex.
It's just basic. It's basic.
I haven't been posting as much lately
and that's because I've been taking a break,
but I am still here. I'm still here for the feminist feed
and I can't wait to make more content with you.